let's get an overview check in right now
with chief White House correspondent
John Roberts at the president's
mar-a-lago Resort even Jeff good evening
to you Brett this is scheduled to start
at 6 o'clock I'm told it will likely
start just a few minutes late so we do
have some time to speak to you to set it
up the big thing to come out of this
summit was only tangentially attached to
it and that was the news that broke last
night that the CIA director Mike Pompeo
back on Easter weekend made a trip to
Pyongyang in North Korea to sit down for
personal talks with the North Korean
leader Kim jong-un to try to set the
stage for an expected summit between
President Trump and Kim jong-un that the
president says could happen sometime in
either late May or early June and the
president has been talking in very
optimistic terms about the possibility
for that sit-down and now we learn the
reason why is because he said the
meeting between Pompeo and Kim was very
successful listen to what he said
earlier today he just the president said
a good relationship was formed with
North Korea yesterday he indicated that
there was a measure of respect that
North Korea had for the United States
but certainly there are questions yet to
be unanswered such as will North Korea
take any confidence-building measures
ahead of the expected summit with the
president such as releasing the three
Americans who continued to be detained
there and what was it that was said to
Pompeo during that meeting brett that
has the president so optimistic now that
North Korea is serious about
denuclearization John I tell you this a
lot of issues as we mentioned coming in
trade a big item on the agenda today as
well what working tell us about that and
this was probably the thorniest issue
between the two leaders I mean clearly
Japan is worried that they want to have
their interests represented at any
meeting with Kim but when it comes to
trade Japan would like to see the United
States back in the trans-pacific
partnership but president Trump is
saying look we've got bilateral trade
deals with six of the 11 nations and we
think we need to have a new free trade
deal with China with
Japan rather Shinzo Abe he doesn't like
that too much she's reluctant to get
into a free trade agreement with the
United States but the president is
pressing hard saying look we've got an
enormous trade deficit with Japan and
his mantra about trade and new trade
deals that he plans to spend this year
crafting bread free fair and reciprocal
the president said that trade deficit is
currently running at about 69 billion
dollars a year we expect that the
Japanese press will have some questions
for president Trump regarding steel
tariffs that have been that are targeted
at Japan to harass on steel and aluminum
Japan being one of our only big allies
Brett that would be subject to those
tariffs to leaders golfing today down
there in Florida last thing John you
know we often talk about how the news
cycle is like drinking from a firehose
and a lot of it depends on what the
president's tweeting today not only
Shinzo Abe a on his mind but maybe some
questions about what he tweeted about
James Comey and also stormy Daniels yeah
clearly James Comey has been on his mind
since he's on his book tour and giving
all of those interviews I don't know
your interview with Comey is is coming
up in the near future Brent but the
president tweeting today about Comey and
rush is saying Slippery James Comey the
worst FBI director in history was not
fired because of the phony Russia
investigation we're by the way there was
no collusion except by the Dems which
would stand in sharp contrast to an
interview that he gave with Lester Holt
a year ago in which the president said
when he went to fire James Comey he was
thinking about quote that Russia thing
and the president also tweeting for the
first time today about stormy Daniels
after stormy Daniels and her attorney
Michael avenatti released that sketch of
a mystery man who stormy Daniels claims
threatened her if she were to say
anything about president Trump tweeted
out this morning was a comparative photo
of that sketch with a man that stormy
Daniels once data there
the right prompting President Trump to
say a sketch years later about a
non-existent man a total con job playing
the fake news media for fools but they
know it tonight Michael avenatti sortin
stormy Daniels attorney is threatening
to file a defamation suit against the
president don't know if that topic will
come up tonight Brett but that's what's
out there all right John thank you